welcome back it is looking like a
bloodbath for joe biden and democrats in
the midterms with americans losing
confidence in them fast liberal comedian
bill maher trying to warn his side over
what's coming
i think they're going to get
thumped in the election i mean that
usually happens in midterm elections but
you know i mean joe look i'm glad he's
there
but uh he has not exactly stuck the
landing on a lot of the issues that he
was dealing with i keep saying this to
the democratic party
the reason why you're so toxic is
because you have become the party of no
common sense we are
should be moving toward a colorblind
society where we don't see race localism
we have to see it everywhere
all the time
so jesse you and i have been doing this
show for almost 20 years
uh
bill maher is saying exactly what we
have been saying but it doesn't matter
because he he reaches people that we
can't right his side he's inside this
bubble so in a weird way he's kind of
doing a heroic deed he's taking the
things that we say on the five and he's
dragging it into his world and forcing
them to hear our common sense it's like
an intervention yes right you wouldn't
have me be the one to do it doing the
interventions you can't you'd have
kennedy or you know anybody but me right
yes that should be the title of your
book
anybody but me this is but this is an
intervention and
and it's good because the left has lost
the plot you had martin luther king
colorblind society that's what we were
all aspiring to until the share of the
white vote started to decrease and then
all of these
coastal college-educated liberals took
over social media and they figured why
don't we just unite all of the
minorities in the country against
traditional white working class
americans and if you do that you can win
the national popular vote that just
pissed everybody off it pissed off
millions of regular normal working-class
people and then it's now starting to
piss off normal democrats so the
democrats need to do this what did
clinton say it's the economy stupid and
i feel your pain not it's the climate
stupid i'm going to cause you pain stick
to the kitchen table issues and that'll
work you know kennedy i'm seeing of
in this weird world a very positive
trend where the strongest voices on the
left which starting with dave rubin bill
maher
glenn greenwald matt taibi
they're all like
understanding
that there's something bad going on and
you're also seeing it on the right where
the right are actually changing their
views on spying and foreign policy and
drug legalization there seems to be a
switch going on and it's very healthy
it is healthy especially if you look at
it from a libertarian perspective
because you see oh if people are
embracing rationalism uh they will
essentially land at a place where
there's limited government where there's
limited government there's self-rule
individual rights and and rationality
above all but when you have something
and bill maher was also asked about the
term woke and how aoc said we don't say
that anymore that's a stupid word only
people over at 50 say that word and bill
maher's like you gave us that word right
that was your term and so now people use
it because in deference to you trying to
be polite and acquiesce to your
silly naive point of view they use terms
like that uh but they they no longer are
so people like that have really split
the party and and jesse's absolutely
right my parents are lifelong democrats
but they look at this party and they do
not recognize it but you also have
people who are new to the party who
don't want to see their taxes go away
and have nothing to show for it when
cardi b first started making money she
was driving around realized there were a
bunch of potholes she's like why am i
paying all this money in taxes and i was
like welcome to
libertarianism good to have you yes you
know geraldo i uh get out of the car to
say it i mean just just you know uh and
she's
gonna stick to the topic
gosh you know it's interesting i know
that bill maher probably is not crazy
about fox news i know that he probably
thinks we're all right wing hacks but to
me i feel like he's becoming an american
hero and by trying to save his own party
he's trying to pull his party away from
a cliff well i think that that's very
perceptive and i and i agree with it
although i am very angry at bill maher
and maine and continue to be because he
owes me one thousand dollars we had a
bet on the air he he said the russia
collusion narrative was true and i said
the russia russia is fake and we bet a
thousand dollars and he never he never
been nor has he invited me back on the
program since because i bust his jobs
he is basically cancel proof right now
one of the few people who who are uh
he can do or say or maintain any
position and i admire the fact that he
is an activist remember what happened to
bill maher and how he got to be cancel
proof he had the show
politically incorrect on abc network a
couple of weeks after 9 11 when
everyone's saying those cowards attacked
us those cowards did this uh bill maher
said wait a second they're not cowards
they're the ones who flew the planes and
died you know maybe uh the the generals
who launched missiles from 3 000 miles
away are the coward so it's very
shocking in that
climate he's very courageous so i've
always been a fan of the best line to
say after a terrorist not two weeks
after the attack but he gave he lost his
show as a result he lost his his
comfortable gig but he created the new
identity here at the uh the hbo show
he's very funny and i hope that people
listen to him but i i with respect i
think that he and grenwald and taibi and
the people that you cite
they're the generation after the ones
that we're talking about the activists
the people who are defining what woke is
what's appropriate and what is not
appropriate and who are busting people's
chops as a result of it they're the
younger yeah i got you yeah that makes
sense emily uh
do you think he is gonna have any impact
or they uh um echoing what heraldo says
or did they say oh he's old he's
irrelevant i was just thinking about
that that those damning labels that are
you know like searing a barbecue stamp
into your forehead um there could be one
that sticks for him but wait quick point
i think you should get your thousand
dollars in the next administration
because under this one it's worth the
equivalent of like five cents your
dollar will go much further
under the exactly under the next
administration um but i just i have to
say that you know he it rings true
because it's simply common sense to your
point jesse the reason that youngkin is
the governor elect of west virginia is
because he campaigned on quote i will or
sorry virginia is he campaigned on quote
i will listen to parents
it's the common sense these guys are
delusional on the left to your point
they've shoved everyone into boxes
thinking that it works we're going to
talk about it in a moment about what
happens in these youth groups that are
eating themselves because everyone is
sticking those labels on each other and
just canceling so bill maher to me he's
just a normal person with common sense
but to your point in the intro i think
it doesn't matter what you say it's who
it is that says it because you've been
screaming this we've all been screaming
this since day one youth groups eating
themselves army hammer's like what